-You were out in Detroit
the last two nights?
-I was.
-Long nights? Late nights?
-Very much.
I was on the late shift.
-Late shift.
-Known as the irrelevant shift
-The irrelevant shift.
You have to stay hydrated.
Important on a long night
like that.
But I have to ask, what was this
in your CNN mug, there?
That is a weird color.
-The blue one?
-Yeah.
-Rocket fuel.
Do you finish up the night
with a large jello shot?
-[ Chuckles ] Yes.
But there's nothing wrong
with that.
-There's nothing wrong
So, what was your takeaway
Obviously it seems as though
ideally, I will say,
for both me and you,
the last time
we have to split it into two
Maybe it will be 10 or les
coming into the September
debates?
-Has to be.
-People are going to have
trouble making the thresholds.
One of the interesting ironies
is that everybody says,
You have to take money
out of politics.
out of the politics."
The main measure of whethe
or not you make the next round
is how much money you rais
between now and then.
So, we have problems.
But you're going to see
that field get smaller.
-It did seem like one of the
things people are talking abou
is how you have
your centrist candidates,
you have
your progressive candidates.
And it seemed like last night,
Joe Biden, to some degree,
was defending Obama's record
a great deal, particularly
in regards to immigration
and in regards to healthcare
Do you find that surprising?
-No. Because I think this part
does not have its head right
I think that -- Not a joke
Good, I'm glad you
didn't take it as one.
I have to work on
the closing argument.
We do the closing argument
every night on the show.
And I'd love your help.
You can go on social media
find me.
I'd really love your help.
I want to do, tonight,
the questions for the Democrats.
My first question is,
why are you doing this?
What is this?
What are you doing?
Is it, I know more about
healthcare
that I can title differently
than your plan
that's almost the exact same
as my plan,
but I won't explain it that wa
because I'm not really
sure what it is?
Is that the why?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right.
-And we applaud, but it's,
like, true.
You know what I mean?
It's like, oh, wait,
that is my new healthcare plan
Why? When you know that
the person you will take o
if you get the nomination is the
president of the United States
is one of the most fearsom
politicians in a generation,
and has already said,
"I will tell you what my plan is
for healthcare
after the election."
-Yeah.
-So you're not going to have
a granular policy debate.
And even if you were, you should
still right now be obsesse
with convincing Americans
that you understand
what they're experiencing
right now --
Why it is unacceptable to them
and why they are desperate
for better.
Two reasons,
one, that's what beat your ass
the last time is your inabilit
to do that,
and that's what we need
as leadership.
But I don't see it on the stage.
I didn't see it either night
And I watched the whole time
-I also watched the whole time
and I did think it got reall
in the weeds on healthcare
But in their defense,
right off the bat,
those were the questions.
I think it's very hard when it's
immediately framed to Kamala
Joe Biden said this
about your healthcare plan
and then it's Joe, Kamala said
this about your healthcare plan.
It does seem like --
Do you feel as though
there should be more room
for candidates at debates
to talk about what you're
talking about as opposed t
the fact that it immediately
drills down, and hey,
now we're talking about this
Define your plan versus
the other.
-Well, two answers, just in case
one doesn't work.
[ Laughter ]
The first answer is,
on your show,
you're told very clearly,
"If you don't answer
what Seth tells you,
you will never be
on this show again."
-Very clearly. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't do that
in my business.
So you know what happens a lot
And this is really
going to shock you.
We ask questions,
and they don't answer them
-Yeah.
-So they make the choice.
All you do -- Look, we're both
good friends with Jake Tapper.
-Yeah.
-Who I believe is
without question one of th
smartest people in the business.
He was with Dana Bash
and this guy named Don Lemon
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
New kid on the block.
-Yeah.
I'm in a cab in Detroit,
this guy turns around and goes
"I recognized your voice,
you're Chris Lemon."
[ Laughter ]
At least let me know, well
we're not that far away
from understanding
that black and white
can get along,
because you confused me
with a black guy.
So, great. So here's the thing
We ask them the question,
they do what they will
with the opportunity.
Jake, Dana, and Don,
they provide the opportunity
Here's the subject matter.
You don't have to
go granular on me.
You don't have to tell me
what the middle class
is going to do because
you can't know
how you're going to get it done.
You don't know what
the state of play will be.
You don't know
who the players will be.
You don't know if you will hav
both houses of Congress or not
So why be in the extreme of ho
you will get something don
when you know people
don't believe
it's going to go that way.
You're missing opportunities
to connect with them
about what their anxieties are
And you're creating somethin
that we can't understand.